os quería hablar de áfrica y yo
estoy encantado
zarzamora
y que voy a decir yo de áfrica porque yo
no soy un experto en áfrica pero me
apetece hablar de áfrica porque es de
las realidades que más me han
sorprendido en los últimos años y por
eso quiero hablar de la áfrica que viene
el áfrica que viene es una áfrica muy
diferente a la que conocí a la que yo
conocí todos somos herederos de nuestro
tiempo y efectivamente sobre áfrica que
es un concepto muy unitario por parte de
todos nosotros pero en cambio encarna
una realidad muy diversa grandiosa y que
está en transformación
quería que anotar 6 esta fotografía que
además la sección de víctor amela hace
poco entrevistó esto es así ya fuse y ni
me gustaría que os quedasteis su rostro
su expresión porque encarna el poder la
fuerza la ambición de áfrica de la
áfrica que viene
todos somos herederos de nuestro tiempo
y efectivamente que es para casi todos
nosotros
áfrica pues áfrica es un gran patrimonio
natural es una gran reserva de la
biodiversidad y efectivamente los que en
los 70 no leíamos tanto como víctor
amela y veíamos más la televisión pues
nos acordamos de la serie de félix
rodríguez de la fuente allí descubrimos
una imagen clarísima de áfrica
áfrica es patrimonio áfrica es también
tribus otro gran tópico de áfrica
y efectivamente hemos leído cosas cómics
el tintín de hace muchas décadas que
expresaba también una imagen de que ha
quedado calada en la imagen de mucha
gente y efectivamente tintín representa
algo así como para mis hijos el rey
león' también y yo también porque él
mufasa el timón y pumba yo lo he visto
centenares de veces
y esto refuerza la imagen tópica de
áfrica
qué jingle toni que ying el más famoso
de una marca pero que también reforzaba
un tópico de áfrica los conguitos en la
infancia y la juventud
aquí el paradigma prototipo de familia
africana
después modernizada en mi juventud con
greystoke y efectivamente también el
cine el cómic la literatura muchas veces
ha forjado una imagen tópica de áfrica
vino la juventud y en la juventud yo me
acuerdo 18 años la toma de conciencia de
áfrica como espacio de guerra y hambre y
aún me emociono cuando pensaba en el
hambruna de etiopía que generó por
ejemplo
a partir de la guerra vino el hambre y
allí surgió por ejemplo en el 85 todos
nos acordaremos todos no porque hay de
gente muy joven aquí lo que fueron dos
grandes conciertos a favor para luchar
contra el hambre pero era una
aproximación de vamos a ayudar
áfrica
a la vez que regalábamos y vendíamos
armas a áfrica ambas cosas
bueno allí surgió en la juventud una
aproximación que era bueno que siempre
ha apoyado ha intentado apoyar
organizaciones que han hecho ayuda al
desarrollo de áfrica lo cual es algo
importante que se tiene que mantener
muchas cosas han cambiado desde entonces
otras no han cambiado
y el áfrica que viene añade otras
dimensiones a las que a las ya conocidas
es decir esta imagen tópica típica de
áfrica
ahora tiene y está viviendo para mí yo
creo que cuatro grandes revoluciones
cuatro grandes transformaciones que
forjan la el áfrica que viene el áfrica
que viviremos los próximos años y las
próximas décadas
la revolución demográfica es evidente se
pensad que ahora son mil millones de
personas dentro de unas décadas serán la
segunda gran área del mundo y está al
lado y la desconocemos por tanto aquí
hay una gran revolución demográfica
estamos al lado del continente que este
siglo más crecerá
ved lo que representa la proporción el
trozo negro es áfrica representará más
de un tercio de la población mundial a
finales de este siglo
esta es una revolución una revolución
inmensa
de la que evidentemente uno de los
fenómenos es la inmigración
uno de los fenómenos es la inmigración
que vienen hacia continentes que
habíamos sido los grandes países
emisores de población durante muchas
décadas y ahora recibiremos una parte de
áfrica
y con esto forjaremos nuevas
oportunidades
la revolución segunda isla de las
ciudades crece la población y áfrica se
urbaniza pensad que en el año en el que
yo nací solo 40 millones de personas en
áfrica vivían en ciudades
por eso félix rodríguez de la fuente
filmaba el áfrica real de los 60 y 70
que era básicamente rural pero en el
ahora el 41% 541 millones de africanos
son ciudadanos ya de urbes de ciudades
sea segunda revolución la urbanización
el crecimiento de las ciudades en áfrica
la tercera ahora se llama disruptiva la
tecnológica áfrica que marc a muchas
etapas y muchos servicios que nosotros
hemos visto evolucionar durante muchas
décadas de repente irrumpe la tecnología
y áfrica pues recoge el poderío
transformador de la tecnología
aquí hay un ganadero del norte de ghana
con un móvil y a partir de este móvil se
genera un gran desarrollo de futuro es
una gran oportunidad
las tres primeras revoluciones la
demográfica la urbana la tecnológica más
o menos yo las conocía habíamos leído
habíamos visto nos lo habían explicado
pero si hoy yo estoy aquí es porque yo
ignoraba totalmente la cuarta yo estoy
aquí por la cuarta razón
por la cuarta revolución
y esta es la revolución que yo he visto
y hemos descubierto con algún amigo que
me acompaña solo hace dos años
y es la revolución del talento del
talento de áfrica de la gente de los
hombres y mujeres de áfrica
y efectivamente muy brevemente yo lo he
descubierto porque generamos un proyecto
que es aceleración de empresas que es
[ __ ] proyectos cuando se inician los
proyectos empresariales y ayudarles a
través de una metodología a crecer a
desarrollar lo hemos hecho desde una
aceleradora norteamericana que un amigo
mío descubrió en lima gente de barcelona
que descubren en lima una aceleradora
norteamericana este es el mundo actual y
efectivamente a través de una
metodología selecciones de empresas las
aceleras aquí en barcelona y después se
presentan porque han hecho un salto que
les permite en una sesión como ésta
presentarse ante el mercado y decir
hemos crecido hemos aprendido y
esperemos que confiéis en nosotros y
después hacemos un seguimiento de cinco
años a estas empresas
cuál fue la sorpresa que nosotros esta
aceleración es de impacto social
no queremos acelerar gentes que
multipliquen por mil su valor porque nos
interesa el impacto social el que cuando
alguien crece genera el desarrollo de
los objetivos de desarrollo sostenible
cuando nosotros aplicamos y aquí vino la
sorpresa y por eso digo que mi sorpresa
es la sorpresa que mucha gente tiene con
áfrica y por eso la quiero compartir es
que la sorpresa fue que hicimos una call
internacional una llamada internacional
y se presentaron más de 220 proyectos
empresariales
y más del 80% eran de áfrica y nosotros
no esperábamos esto
y por eso nos sorprendió tanto
casi 200 proyectos de los 220 eran de
personas de ghana de uganda de nigeria
hubo también un proyecto ganador de
india
esto fue para mí la gran sorpresa porque
es verdad
belarmino que nos asustamos y quiero
compartir que cuando lo vimos nos
asustamos
y en cambio ahora pues yo estoy aquí en
una teta en una sesión de ted explicando
que esta es la gente más maravillosa que
yo nunca he conocido
y que son un gran ejemplo y que además
son la oportunidad y el futuro para
áfrica
porque es gente que a través del talento
la necesidad la ambición la capacidad
ahora le llaman resiliencia de
levantarse cuando uno recibe el golpe de
la realidad
pues son capaces de hacer una empresa
que a través de plataformas digitales
prestan cosas porque ellos vienen de la
cultura de compartir y ahora le han
puesto tecnología a esta cultura de
compartir
y este es un proyecto de dos chicos de
nigeria
la cultura de compartir puesta al
servicio de la tecnología o mejor la
tecnología al servicio de esta cultura
ancestral
una señora abigail que siempre ha visto
como las mujeres trabajaban la yuca y
ella está trabajando para hacer un
proyecto para poner medios mecánicos que
permitan aumentar muchísimo la
productividad y que la yuca no se pudra
en los almacenes de las aldeas sino que
pueda ser transformada comercializada y
generar desarrollo
esta es abigail y hecha y ella ha hecho
un impacto importantísimo porque esta
pequeña aquí gran inversión allá
transforma la vida de centenares de
mujeres campesinas en áfrica
o peter que peter está generando
cooperativas procesos de
para generar el pollo a nivel industrial
el pollo la gran vía' de proteína en
nigeria níger ya que ya tiene casi 300
millones de habitantes y que por tanto
es un país que necesita la proteína y el
pollo de manera industrial puede generar
esta proteína
hussein y una mujer musulmana de una
población que la casaron joven
y que ya vio como desde siempre trataban
el carite
y ella sobre esta realidad agrícola de
mujeres ha generado un proyecto
empresarial para convertir esto en un
proceso de más valor añadido generado
allí mismo y que por tanto en ghana se
genere producto con más valor añadido
con más marca para poder después
comercializar en el mundo
y por tanto que el valor se quede en
gana al servicio de la gente de ghana
y efectivamente hace dos años 100
mujeres estaban en este proyecto y ahora
ya son 700 mujeres esto es una
revolución en áfrica
es la mejor y la más grande revolución
por eso allí se la ponía al inicio
porque está en el origen de esta charla
esta charla es para compartir lo que a
mí me pasó que áfrica nos llamó a la
puerta sin querer y nos sorprendió
y ahora efectivamente somos personas que
hemos enseñado cosas pero sobre todo
hemos aprendido muchas cosas de áfrica
y este es el proyecto de peter y a lima
que efectivamente la mortalidad de
ganaderos descoordinados ha dado pie a
través de una plataforma digital a
servicios de asesoramiento de provisión
de vacunas de consolidación de
estructuras productivas que hacen en el
norte de ghana ahora haya muchas más
cooperativas y un mundo conectado
tecnológicamente cuando decimos la
estructura digital que cambia esto es
una gran aplicación
y esto es cambiar la vida en áfrica y
esto es generar desarrollo endógeno y
esto es transformar realmente desde la
base local la realidad de áfrica que
lejos de ser algo amenazante de ser algo
lejano es algo muy próximo y es la gran
oportunidad para europa porque además
hablamos de 'tú a tú' hablamos desde un
mismo nivel ante gente que tiene tanto o
más talento de lo que podamos tener
nosotros esta es la nueva áfrica y es la
el áfrica que viene y está ya está aquí
aunque es verdad que en europa nos
cuesta verla
por tanto tenemos muchas cosas que
aprender de ella y sólo les diría que
allí ya también suman omar osman umar es
aquel chico de 12 años que con 12 años
salió de una aldea de ghana y paso por
todo por todo el desierto fue a libia
después de mauritania y llegó en cayuco
a canarias hasta llegar a las calles de
barcelona
son dos grandes ejemplos guzmán ya es de
ghana y es catalán y después de haber
hecho todo esto a su hermano pequeñito
le dijo tú te quedarás en gana no harás
ni pasarás lo que yo he pasado porque
necesitamos el crecimiento de áfrica con
el orgullo con el conocimiento con la
ambición con la fortaleza de áfrica
y esta es la nueva áfrica que viene
cuanto antes lo veamos antes podremos
cooperar antes podremos crecer juntos
antes podremos transformar la vida de
este magnífico continente que es nuestro
gran vecino muchas gracias
[Aplausos]